NOT EVERYBODY HAACE
NU FEZU
MENTIOPR>> HAN.
FORGIVE MES GO TO PRESIDENT-ELEC
LET'S LISTEN
ALL RIGHT
Y
>> OY.
Y BU, HAVEN'
IS
.S WE NEED EVODY
>> J AHEAD YT TO
ME YOUY.
LOT.
THE CLAL WORK, IT' THERO WORKER
AMAZING.
I TAROHO
E W BUSY INCARD WE OWELLY .OF
E ADMINISTRATION DESERVE
GROUND WITOPN WARP
I ALSO THINK THAT IT'SSAYING THE
G THIS TDENS
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE PREPARED
E  TAKE
O WORRY ABOUI'FORWARD TO
SECOND SHOT, S JILL.
D HER SHOT EARLI
OTS, KNOW.
O MANY THAT IT DOESN
VISIT. ME>> THAT'S R URT SI
BUT THIM THAT
VAE ND MODERNAS E ON THE ROA WE.
IT'S G TO TAKE TIME.
IM IT
HERE, BUI HOPE PPLE LISTEN  ALL
MAS RISTMAD 'SSONCE,IF YOUE TOD
DON'T EL.
ONE THINGO HAVE THE
O GETHE SHOW UP AT A HOSL.
NEEDLE, IN AN D THERE ARE MILLID
THISONKE.
WAN THA
EVERYONE FOR ALL
YOU'RE SOME REALS.
REAL HEROESD YOU'RE
THITYOTHEM.
NOTHING .HOT THE T-ECHIS WITHER
ME TO THANK THE T NEORKERS, THET
AUSE THESE TWO AENE
NOW  MAKE SURE U'RE SOCIAL CI Y.
BUT THERE U  N
NUERF TWO.L WITH MD
JEFFESIDENEC.  YOU WATCHED B
WHAT'S GOI?
I THINK THAT'S A
FOR ALL OFS.
I THK ETNYS MENTIONES O WHEN
HE WAS VACCINATED, MOST OF
THOSE IN THE 75 D OLDEMEER WHER
ED SULVAOW
VAS 5 O.
K IN AMERICAHISTORY THAT
WAA SIMILAR NTO WHW.>>.
YONG THEHOT, BT JOE DEELSHAN
OMING ON THE
EL VICE PRESIDENT MIKEPENCE AND
PEEI.EN RECEING HERSHOT TREOOKEE
VACCINE EARLIER TODA
PHOTO OP
TH
HI
WE'VE NOT HEARD T.
HE SHES THIS
ADMINIOFVACCINE. A SOMRDS OF W N
E. W MKS
ON, E  THIS IS JUST
NI, IT'S  SOMETHING HE'S
DONE TODAYLY SO HE C T SECONDAC
THDIDN'TN W E N
HIS ARM.SEOTOV YEARS, D MAITLL
BI
SH WEEWE-EHARRIS HUSBAND DOUG A
ALSO GOING TO BE RECEIVING A
VEY LIKETHIS, BROO
R THM UT
LAST WEEK  PENCEAND HIS WIFE GE.
A E  I DON'T KNOW IF W
CARD TO THE PRECREMEMBER THIS FN
ALL TH ITHE U.K.
I IMAGE IT'S SIKE,
YNEED TOUE EN
W DOEST WORK PEOPLY AWAI VCI
WORKERS AND RESIDENT-T GOT MINE
I FILLED OUT WHILE IWAITTH AAN L
SECONWEG
THE AVAILABILITY OF VACCINE FOR
A LONG TIME IN THE
Y, SO IT